hello
um thank you for the introduction
um before I begin I just wanted to tell
you a little bit about myself and the
work I do I'm a data scientist based in
New Delhi India I moved there about a
year and a half ago to work in
International Development for my dream
job
um my teammates and I work in low to
Middle income countries to help
governments foundations and non-profits
maximize their impact on issues like
agriculture Education Health governance
and financial inclusion
to give you a flavor of the kind of work
we do
um
sorry here are some problems we solved
we developed models to match citizens to
government benefits and schemes that
they'd be eligible for so that our
partner organization could reach out to
them to receive their social welfare
benefits
we've predicted out of school girls in
rural regions so that our client could
bring 600 000 more out of school girls
back to school and succeed
um
and we allocated a cohort of around 1
000 new teachers to schools based on the
teachers expertise and the school's need
so these are the kinds of projects we
worked on but today I want to tell you
about another project we did this time
in South Africa where maternal deaths
still happen 10 times as more frequently
than they do in high income countries
amale lives in South Africa she's
pregnant and expecting a baby soon
for the past seven months she's been
getting help through mom connect South
Africa's national WhatsApp helpline for
maternal and child health
she gets messages every week about the
changes changes she should expect and
receives reminders for checkups
she also often asks the services help
desk about her challenges
at one point she got really worried that
she couldn't feel her baby move the help
desk got back to her with a reply but
only after hours of wait and as I'll
explain later this was because the help
desk was overburdened each operator
having to answer hundreds of messages
each day
and I want to tell you how we helped
unload the burden on the help desk so
that a pregnant person like a Molly
could get their questions answered
instantly
and we're calling the solution ask a
question or AQ for short
by the end of this talk I hope you'll
know where to start if you were to build
a run an FAQ answering service yourself
understand one example of the kind of
work you can do in International
Development using your technical skills
and this is a bonus for me and my team
give us feedback on the tool I'll
introduce and help us make it better
now let's take a look at the problem we
wanted to tackle
Reach digital health is a South African
organization it's been running mom
connect a national maternal and child
helpline child health helpline since
2014.
and just like amale folks expecting
babies would sign up through a clinic
get the timely messages about checkups
reminders physical changes they should
expect and ask questions to train
professionals at the help desk
in 2018 over 95 percent of clinics and
60 percent of all pregnant women in
South Africa were signed up and it's
only grown since then with 450
000 active users currently and all that
is to say it has and still has the
potential to impact millions of people
going through pregnancy and birth in
South Africa
and as I touched on earlier
users could send their questions to the
help desk Within momconnect
but the help desk could be operated by
only a few operators which meant they
were overburdened with hundreds of
questions each day as I said this lead
this led to some users having to wait
hours to get their questions answered
um and with
limited Human Resources we wanted to
ensure that only the most urgent or
tricky questions would go to the help
desk
wherever possible instantly addressed
user questions with accurate medical
content
um another important context is that
reach is running other helplines too
and that not every helpline could be
equipped with a help desk with trained
operators
in 2020 they launched covid-19 connect
um and because they had to launch this
quickly they weren't able to set up a
help desk
and in fact this is when we came up with
our first version of ask a question
solution and our former colleague Adam
actually talked about it at Pi data
Global a few years ago
um and last year another helpline was in
preparation for launch called young
Africa live a helpline for teenage
sexual health
in these cases we needed a way to answer
user questions without relying on any
help desk
yes to enable that we needed some
plug-in for the helplines this would be
something that takes in a user question
looks at the available FAQs and outputs
FAQs that are most likely to answer the
question
specifically for Mom connect we were
aiming to reduce the workload on the
help desk operators by 50 initially and
since momconnect shows the top five FAQs
that means we want the top five to
contain the correct FAQ at least 50
percent of the time and other times the
questions would go to the help desk
and will be answered by humans what kind
of data science model would we need on
the back end we would need something
that again takes in user question as an
input and outputs a match score for each
of the FAQs then we take the top FAQs
according to the match scores and show
show the top ones to the users and if
you've done an NLP project or two you
might already have some ideas about how
to build a model like that and we'll get
into some things we ended up building
but I wanted to touch on some
restrictions or requirements we had to
we we had for a service like that
um the first restriction was that we
couldn't rely on any external services
userable users will be sending
potentially sensitive medical questions
sometimes they would send their names
things that we don't have control over
and the data must be stored within South
Africa due to South African data
regulations so we can't rely on any like
nlu apis that because we wouldn't have
full control over where the data would
go how it would be used
that meant that we did have to build our
own model
um the second restriction is that we
can't we couldn't build any supervised
models uh what do I even mean by
supervised models um you can imagine if
we had a question FAQ pair data then
like for example we can train a
classifier that would classify any
question into maybe like 70 FAQ contents
but for helplines without any help desk
like covid-19 connect and young Africa
live there wouldn't be any such data
because these are new
uh new services without help desk
um and Mom connect only had questions
data and the FAQ labels would have been
expensive to produce
another thing is FAQs could be added
removed rearranged based on like
people's needs so training a classifier
would have been too rigid so we needed
an unsupervised approach one that would
take any user question and FAQ pair and
be able to come up with a match score
how about requirements for the service
since there were repeated use cases for
AQ we wanted to make it easy to roll out
a new instance of AQ quickly
um as I'll introduce as I introduce my
team's solution I would like you to keep
these requirements in mind and I'd also
be curious to hear when you had to build
a model called start or how to deal with
data regulations and if you can think of
any alternative approaches
be very curious to hear
um but I'll share what worked for us
which I'm calling AQ and I'll walk you
through its components including the FAQ
answering models we used how you can use
these models through a library because
we built called fact
and how to use the template applications
to easily launch a new instance of aeq
let's start with the FAQ matching models
I'll discuss two approaches that worked
best one that used word embeddings and
word movers distance and another that
relied on Bert let's look into them one
by one
and our first approach we rely on the
word embeddings and as many of you know
I'm sure these are vector
representations of words such that the
relative positions of words in this
Vector space mirror the semantic
relationships among the words as in the
example here words similar and meaning
would be close together like media and
press
let's look at how the model Works in
full given the user question and one of
the FAQs and the FAQ database we first
tokenized them and look up those tokens
in the word embedding model to get the
word vectors
to get a match score between a question
and an FAQ we compute What's called the
word movers distance between the
question vectors and the FAQ vectors
this will be done for every single FAQ
in the FAQ database to produce the match
scores which we use to rank the FAQs
um what is board movers distance let's
look at this diagram from the original
paper by Kushner the word movers
distance between the left and the right
documents is the minimum distance that
the words from the left document would
have to travel to arrive at the words in
the second document and by words here I
mean word vectors
um
and if there are different numbers of
tokens some words would get split so
part of it travels to one word and part
of it travels to another
uh in summary the word movers distance
score represents tokens as word vectors
and we get the score by getting the word
movers distance between question vectors
and FAQ vectors
to start this without any data you do
need some sort of pre-trained word
embedding and it's great when you have
absolutely no data and no data science
capacity to train any models
but if you have some data science
capacity and if you have some unlabeled
data like as in the case of mom connect
you can potentially make improvements by
training your own word embedding on the
domain-specific Corpus which is what we
did for Mom connect
um let's move on to the next approach
and our second approach we took
inspiration from Mass and chechik's
paper and used Bert or this Dilbert more
precisely but any kind of bird model
would work and to give you a quick recap
Bert is a Transformer based language
model that was pre-trained to predict
Mass tokens in the sentence and the next
in the next sentence in a text this led
to a powerful latent representation of
tokens and sentences within the context
of other words
in the text
um and following uh mass and chechik's
work we added a single layer neural
network on top of Bert which would be
trained to score a FAQ sorry question
FAQ pair so working from the bottom of
the diagram we would we first feed the
question FAQ document pair through Bert
and use the aggregate representation
Vector feed it through a fully connected
layer to get the final match score
now to train the top feed forward layer
you do need some sort of training data
that means we first need to come up with
synthetic questions for each FAQ ideally
they'd be phrase realistically with
typos and grammatical errors and cover
all different questions that could be
answered by a particular FAQ
um then we create a data set of
synthetic question FAQ pairs labeled
them as having label 1.0 of perfect
match score and for each FAQ we also
randomly sampled some negative example
as an irrelevant questions and assigned
them label 0.0 so match score of zero
this is what we use to train the final
feed forward layer
um it does require some effort of coming
up with the example questions initially
but because Bert is pre-trained on you
know a massive data set we were able to
get great results with just four to five
questions for FAQ
um with question answered Bert score we
used Bert to represent the question FAQ
pair and used a small synthetic data set
to train a single layer neural network
to predict the match scores
um again this requires some example
questions and the Bert model itself
and if you can bear the GPU cost and
have some data science capacity to train
the model could be a good good
alternative
so which model was better on the test
data for Mom connect boasted equally
well with a top 5 accuracy of 62 percent
which comfortably exceeds our Target of
50 percent
um but for a mom connect we decided to
go with the word movers distance score
for to start with because it was lighter
and hence cheaper to maintain than vert
and of course the performance might look
different as we run the service and
collect label data to train and improve
the models with but initially and in
resource constrained settings we can't
always resort to the latest and the
fanciest and simpler Solutions can work
just as well
so we've packaged these models into a
library called fact the intention here
is to provide a suite of models for FAQ
matching that's appropriate under
different circumstances and let me give
you an example of how it works let's say
we want to use the word movers distance
score we first need to load some
pre-trained Ward embedding into a keyed
Vector object like gen Sims work to back
we also need a list of FAQs
and now you can create the scoring
object using fact by feeding it the word
embedding and we call set contents
method to feed the feqs in the scoring
object
and whenever a new question comes query
the model using score contents and it
should return the match score for each
of the FAQs
so zooming out again to make it easy to
serve the model as a service we created
application templates for AQ
um the applications are built in flasks
consisting of the core app and the admin
app which read and write to the database
for the FAQs and to keep a record of
model outputs
the core app serves the fact model and
I'll just show and show you an example
how of how it works
so here the user has already expressed
the desire to ask a question to the help
desk
um
and
yeah
so they typed their question in uh here
with a typo
and they send the message and what's
happening on the back end is the chat
service is calling the core app to get
the FAQ match score so the core app is
using fact model to make create the
scores and it records those this message
and the model output into the database
and
um shows the top five that should answer
the question and the user can select the
FAQ that seems to best answer their
question and view the entire content
like so
um
read more and at the end uh we ask for
feedback so
yeah we ask if this uh if this answered
their question and if and when the user
gives feedback the chat service will
ping the core apps feedback endpoint to
attach this feedback to the question and
the model output that we had so we use
this data to Monitor and improve a model
performance
um now I'd like to show you
the AQ admin app which um our clients
content managers use
so this is for managing FAQ contents and
testing the FAQ matching endpoint and uh
to also to manage the fact model
configurations
and I'll just show you how it works uh
I recorded it because I didn't want to
Fumble
um you can view them
FAQs here you can add edit and delete
stuff here
um and you can see an example of the
edit page for an FAQ
and we can also test the core apps FAQ
matching endpoints so if a content
manager wants to check which if the
content that they added would get get
floated up with like certain questions
they can test
um
it's a pretty simple stuff but super
useful for the content managers
so
um
yes uh what is aq's impact
um so according to Beta Testing results
so not on the test data but on like real
world data
um 58 of the use uh user feedback was
positive meaning AQ instantly answered
58 of the questions with accurate and
relevant medical advice
which meant that mob connects help desk
workload was significantly reduced and
AQ allowed the help desk operators to
focus more on urgent and tricky
questions regarding maternal and child
health
so in closing
uh what have we seen today I've shown
you how you can use AQ to quickly create
your own version of an FAQ answering
service by showing two different FAQ
matching models how you can use fact
library to use those models and how you
can serve the model and manage the
content using AQ template applications
we also saw that in resource constraint
settings like having no data or smaller
budget we may not be able to Resort use
state-of-the-art and that simpler
Solutions can work well too
and finally we saw that AQ had a real
impact on the operation of mom connect
which we hope contributes to improving
maternal and child health in South
Africa
but is AQ the answer uh we know better
performance as possible and we certainly
don't want to reinvent the wheel
many of you might know of Rafa I think
there was a talk about it earlier it's a
popular open source framework for
building chat Bots we want to explore
the possibility of providing fact models
as custom components of rasa and since
rasa has already already has a wide user
base more people can take advantage of
the FAQ matching models that I showed
you
and with the Advent of so many easily
accessible large language models there's
so much potential to improve not just
the FAQ matching model but the user
experience in general
and we're exploring how we can use
powerful embeddings like open AI
embeddings while adhering to data
regulations
and I'd love to hear your ideas as well
and this is all open source open for
your contribution and critique you can
check out the repositories here and if
you have ideas about potential use cases
what parts of it you found useful if
there are some obvious things that you
think we're missing
Etc my team and I would love to hear
from you
um and finally I'd like to point out
that if you think about it nothing we
did was revolutionary and with your
technical skills I think all of you have
a huge potential to help improve lives
and the less well-off parts of the world
um I hope you'll entertain that
potential and if you're interested
please check out the link here or talk
to me after the talk and I'd like to
thank Reach digital health for their
Partnerships goal foundation for funding
the work and my team at ID Insight we're
working on this together and thank you
for listening
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much for this talk
we have a couple of questions
the first one is
what is the reason that you have
included negative examples in the bird
training
so
you're training the model to basically
discriminate between cases so
how do I put this
um
because for for when the question comes
in you want to go through all of the
FAQs in the database to see which ones
are the best matches right and so for
the FAQs that are like the wrong answers
you want the model to Output zero so it
needs like those wrong matches to learn
that these are these are not the right
matches I hope that answered the
question
yeah yeah that makes sense next one have
you tried sentence embeddings that can
be fine-tuned and good models are open
source in hogging phase yeah yes uh we
have experimented initially and didn't
pursue it but we should probably look
into it more one thing is we did try
openai embeddings with like anonymized
data and it's like the performance is
really impressive it's just we don't
have we haven't figured out a way to use
it uh while complying with South African
data regulation but we are talking about
how we can use it yeah
okay nice next one is what is your
inspiration to use bird instead of T5
GPT or something like that
I do not know what that is and please
come to me after the talk and teaching
what it is yeah I actually don't know
what T5 is myself
do you use the word embeddings per word
or do you aggregate the word embeddings
for the full questions and answers
[Music]
approach is we are using it by word but
um
yeah
the nice thing about this is that like
you can compare like a set of vectors
two sets of vectors
um and you don't need to aggregate them
per se you can just compare like how
much does do these vectors have to like
travel to arrive at the others and
that's if if the vectors are close
together like they wouldn't really have
to travel much right
um
so no aggregation needed
all right what service did you use for
running the dialog flow oh that one uh
so our client reached digital Health uh
has a open source like WhatsApp
thing called turn.io I think and also I
think rapid this rapid flow is a popular
one for like creating those dialogue
flows
um I think turn.io is for managing
um users and what that flows but yeah
all right how large is your FAQ Corpus
[Music]
so it is quite long but
um
not huge so that's that's why it's
possible for us to compare like get the
questions
uh compare each FAQ
um I know like for if you're like doing
text search I know like it's a different
problem you need to um
I know there are like specialized
databases for that and such but ours was
simple
okay um next one is did you also
experiment with other embedding methods
such as bird for work movers distance
model instead of word to vector God
I guess why not but I think with bird
the thing is
like it's it already has quite like
powerful representations of like the
tokens and the sentences
um that yeah we didn't think to
experiment with it but yeah maybe
it's worth a try
okay
um did you consider using sense to
Vector instead of default word to vector
uh so I think that that's talking about
like sentence embeddings and yeah I
think I may have no it's a different one
part of speech
that's over the black model training its
own part of speech as well
oh interesting okay no I I did not know
about that yeah
all right
um why is the question answering model
better to a search-based approach what
do you think
[Music]
so I think there's like the the Baseline
actually at Tobias gave a talk about
like typical baselines for a different
text NLP problems and I think you
mentioned bm25 as a good Baseline
um for us the way the users ask
questions would be like so different
from like the FAQ contents themselves
that it wasn't
yeah bn25 was inappropriate for our case
um regarding that model what if a user
asks a question out of context how do
you handle that
uh so we would
we would have to like threshold the
score so that like we we don't want to
always output like the top five right if
the scores are overall really low then I
think we would just have to say like in
the service flow like we we did not
understand your question like could you
rephrase it something like that no
um sorry
um if a user asks a question out of
context
is there
anyway you deal with that
uh
you can come up to me and clarify the
question I sorry I didn't understand it
properly yeah
I guess so it's similar yeah
yeah thresholding I guess yeah but if if
I understood it incorrectly please come
up then I'd be happy to talk
um because it is related to health you
would want to get the highest Precision
possible
how could you get to a reliable
Precision using an unsupervised model
so
I mean I don't think we are confident
about the Precision like uh the the the
good thing is that we have human in the
loop right we have built-in mechanism
for someone to escalate it if this
doesn't like if you think about it 40 of
the time people aren't getting their
questions answered either they're like
really they just want to talk to a human
because it's urgent and they don't care
about they don't care to read through or
like or our model isn't performing well
but it's yeah I think just having human
in the loop is key and will collect more
more data to improve the model as we go
forward
um
May some kind of automatic spelling
correction improve your process as word
vectors won't handle them
[Music]
but with like mob connect we use fast
text which doesn't have a fixed
dictionary and actually spell correction
didn't improve the performance that much
if I remember correctly
um yeah
but definitely worth all right so uh I
guess last question before I'll leave
you into the coffee break did you
consider FAQ paraphrasing
uh through I'm sorry I don't know what
that is Beth translation for generating
more data
we need to generate the example
questions and
um
yeah yeah I think they actually use GPT
to like generate examples I didn't think
about like
paraphrasing the FAQs themselves
um but yeah like
using GPT or some generative model to
like augment the data could be a
promising approach I think yeah
I didn't I we didn't try it yeah
thank you very much give it up for us
Eugene
[Applause]